when I was eight years old I was bought
a pair of black patent leather shoes I
adored these shoes more than any toy I
didn't use a wheelchair then but this
was a phase in my young life when I was
urged to wear sensible shoes the horror
of that time burns in me to this day
well fitting plane shoes surely a shoe
should be appropriate to your
circumstances and if a shoe is
comfortable it's best for you but who
wants to wear only dull shoes whether
you're 8 or 88 who wouldn't feel
rebellion against a constant what his
best
rhetoric those nagging didn't realize
that the more my kitten heels and slick
platform boots were condemned as bad the
more I would wear them and I did like
many women I'm sure spraining ankles and
contorting toes now miss a wheelchair
user it's ironic that I wear shoes as an
accessory and not for walking I recently
tried on some beautiful size 3 Louboutin
heels I stroked them then left them in
the shop but only because of the
outrageous price
you